foreign
welcome to the show
thank you thank you for taking my crawl
sure how can we help today
uh well I'm looking for some advice on
how to invest 120
000 in cash whoa I am retired in 2010
from my first job
I've been working a second job full-time
now and over the years I've saved a lot
of money
and I've got about three different bank
accounts with money in so I'm
financially good there but I have 120
000 and 10 cans buried in the backyard
that ain't making me no money wow I
thought I would try to find out
what I can do we finally found the guy
with the tin cans of money in the
backyard wow let's start with your
address where exactly can we find let's
go on a treasure hunt
Jim's like he's like my name's not Jim
and I don't live in Austin
Well if I told you I'd have to shoot you
oh man I believe you Jim I totally I'm
not going here Jim's property so you've
done a great job saving do you have any
debt
they have no debt whatsoever in 2010 I
paid everything off and I have worked
some for the municipality that I work
for now and I do a lot of security jobs
on the side and I have been able to
really really save a lot of money the
wife is retired and I should be retired
I'm at 67 years old but do you just like
working
I do like working I don't like sitting
at home when I retired in 2010 I stayed
retired six months didn't like it so I
got a job good for you that's awesome
okay how much money do you have do you
have anything invested or is this all
just sitting in checking accounts and
savings accounts
well I have uh two bank accounts two
different banks and then I have a credit
union with some money into these too so
those three accounts is only making
whatever the interest rate is for the
banks oh that stinks no it's not What's
the total of all that money that's in
the banks
uh about 125 000. okay so you got 125 in
Banks and then 120 000 in cash and
you're wanting to invest this
and I wanted to invest at least the 120
000 cash because I know it's not making
me any money well even your the money
that's sitting in those Banks you could
do way better in a high yield savings
account you could be making three or
four percent on that instead of you know
zero to a half percent
okay well that's what the advice I need
and how to do that and what to do to get
to that point now I would tell you I
have a CD for the wife and one of your
accounts for six thousand so there's
another six thousand there and then I do
invest uh in the 457 program I'm not
sure if you're aware of that how that
works through the county is that like a
deferred compensation
exactly okay and I have about 15
000 in that so do you have any
retirement options through your current
employer
yes what are those options
well I'm drawing an annuity from my
first job
uh considerable amount of money I'm
drawn Social Security
because I'm at 66 in two months I'm
going full Social Security there how
much you have a 401k or anything through
work
no okay so it's the uh two to one match
through the county
uh I was a tmrs before when I was
retired but from the other one now it's
a Texas Municipal County Retirement
okay both of them are good retirements
so do you need the income created from
these Investments are you living off of
the annuity and Social Security Plus
your current income
that's what I'm living off of I don't
really use this other money for anything
other than just sitting there okay even
in the even in the bank accounts
uh just let it sit there
so I would leave enough to have a fully
funded emergency fund and that
high-yield savings account and it sounds
like you'd be more comfortable having
more money in there are you going to
plan on making any big purchases in the
next few years
no okay you've got to pay for house
yes sir great so the full the first
Focus you want to look into is tax
advantaged accounts meaning things that
have some kind of tax implication that
can help you avoid paying Uncle Sam uh
his due
and so that would be things like a 401k
or anything Roth so a Roth IRA what's
your household income
uh for it's just me right now so it's uh
let's see 30 30 60
probably around 90 to 100 000 a year
okay
yeah you've got options to make this
work a whole lot more for you than these
bank accounts and so beyond tomorrow the
wife starts on her social security so
we'll have her income payday yes well
you guys have done really well I mean I
know it hurts to look back and go man
over the 12 years this Money's been
sitting here it could have grown at you
know eight to ten twelve percent and
instead it just you know couldn't beat
inflation
um but I could kick myself for letting
it sit there but uh well let's look to
the Future and and be be uh comfortable
I need some advice and some help to get
some kind of investments in it yeah well
I would for sure you need to connect
with an investing professional who can
walk you through all of your options and
dig into all the details and we've got
some that we vet all over the country we
have some of the Austin Texas area that
can help you if you just jump onto
ramseysolutions.com and click on Ramsay
recommends you can connect with a
smartvester pro and they'll walk you
through hey Jim here's all of your
options that we could do with this money
they're not going to force you to do
anything you still call the shots
they're just going to educate you on
what you could do and where to invest
that money to help it grow they're
probably going to recommend things like
mutual funds these are groups of
hundreds and thousands of stocks that
can help your money grow with way less
risk than just a single stock when one
company
okay that's an example there's index
funds that you could also invest in
which are just tracking you know like
the S P 500 tracking the top 500
publicly traded companies and their
growth we're kind of all banking that's
what the economy is really based on when
we look at the stock market is that S P
500 so there's a lot of options and uh
you know you you still got time how old
are you
I'm 67. so I mean Jim we still got you
know what 30 years ahead of us here to
to invest this money and let it grow
hope so yes sir you got kids what I'm
looking for
uh yes but they're all married and grown
and I've got uh three grandkids and one
on the way I love that well you know I'm
a Bible believer man and it says a good
man leaves an inheritance to his
children's children and so that's a
great goal for you to have well I do
have I do have for the three that I
already have I do have bank accounts for
them set up at the credit union love it
man well you're off to a great start
you've got some homework to do Jim which
is let's research a good high yield
savings account uh there's there's a ton
out there you can look into Marcus by
Goldman Sachs or Ally we don't have any
affiliation with them you just want to
make sure they're FDIC insured which
means your money's covered just like it
would be with that credit union and
those for sure are and then connect with
that smart investor Pro and get
investing don't just leave this sitting
in the checking account breaks my heart
I hear you got six figures that have
been sitting out there for over a decade
man but you've done really well and
being debt free really helps the
situation Jade we love to hear that so
thanks for the college in